a scientific picture of the world is
largely objective its mechanisms one
thing after another the neuron causes
the neuron which sends a signal which
causes an action we've got a beautiful
scientific picture of that
where does subjective experience fit in
we live in a simulation or reality I'm
going to assume for the purpose of this
discussion that there is a real world
and this is not completely accepted but
I'm going to assume there is a real
world but you've never lived there
it's not going to be
within the competence of neuroscience to
describe or explain adequately what a
young man or woman undergoes when they
fall in love or what is involved in
loving another person
we've talked about experienced people
in CV terms and what's your experience
tell us a bit about your experience it
can just refer to the things you've done
but we're going to be looking at it and
a slightly more I guess for the soft
core where you know experience the
nature of experience what it what it is
to experience things how we are in the
world how we process experience whether
it remains mysterious or not whether we
can subject all of experience to
scientific or philosophical method or
indeed whether there'll be aspects of
experience which will always elude our
capacity to grasp it
our official topic is experience I don't
know what experience is but I'm inclined
to take experience as a synonym for what
I call consciousness the reason I do
that is I know something about
consciousness experience who knows but
consciousness you know there's a there's
a very good definition of consciousness
which I like it's that annoying time
between naps there's that time when
you're actually having subjective
experiences of the world I'm like saying
when you're when you're asleep or at
least not dreaming I mean if I was asked
to define consciousness we don't
actually end up going in a tight circle
my favorite dip if I was give an
official definition of consciousness I'd
say it's the subjective experience of
the mind and of the world
so notice there I used the word
experience right there and I think the
crucial thing about this notion of
experience is it's subjective experience
it's experience from a subjective point
of view experience from a first-person
point of view when I look out at this
audience right now I see all of you I
think I'm naturally said to have visual
experiences subjectively it's like
something for me to see you there are
colors and there are there are shapes
this is a visual experience there's
something it's like for me to see I'm
having auditory experiences there's
something that's like for me to hear
there's something it's like to feel my
body I'm having proprioceptive
experiences there's something it's like
for me to think to remember so I think
if this is all so it's a massive
multi-stream movie if you if you like if
you don't don't take that metaphor too
seriously experience is basically what
it's like to have a mind from the
first-person point of view and the big
mystery is I think this is the most
important phenomenon in the world as far
as I'm concerned it's not just because I
make my living thinking and and writing
about it I think experience is what
gives our life meaning it's what gives
our life value you know for what if we
weren't experiencing creatures our lives
would be in an important sense I think
be meaningless and and valueless but at
the same time we don't understand
all this phenomenon fits in to our
scientific picture of the world a
picture of the world is almost a
scientific picture of the world is
largely objective its mechanisms one
thing after another the neuron causes
the neuron which sends a signal which
causes an action we got a beautiful
scientific picture of that where does
subjective experience fit in it looks
like you can tell the whole story about
the brain without mentioning conscious
experience so hopefully today in the
next hour or so we're gonna figure out
the answer hopefully we are thanks David
on I'll move on to Susanna in a second
just a quick follow-up you said right at
the beginning you know experience is
like consciousness the annoying thing
that happens between naps so you're
bringing together experience and
consciousness pretty Chloe's pretty
closely so is the notion of unconscious
experience impossible I think there can
be for example unconscious perception I
mean it's clear there are there are
cases where someone is exposed to a
certain stimulus doesn't report seeing
anything but it still affects their
action and we certainly call that
unconscious perception I would not
myself call that an experience precisely
because it doesn't feel like anything
from the inside this is to some extent
verbal what you got to call an
experience but I reserved the word
experience for something that feels like
something subjectively if it does that
then in my view it's also a conscious
first person experience I guess that's
something is like happening to us in the
world that we have these feelings about
ourselves of these perceptions I see in
the in debris things that I'm supposed
to have the position that experience is
in the material world now I'm not a
philosopher so I don't exactly know what
the material world is but I'm gonna say
I'm gonna rephrase that as saying that
experience is generated in the brain and
the brain is part of the physical
universe obeys natural laws and so I
believe that I we're not there yet but
eventually we're gonna be able to be
able to explain experience in terms of
neuroscience and one of the limitations
of our experience and actually one of
the strengths that we have one of the
tools that we have to approach the study
of experience from a neuroscientific
point of view is that experience does
not match reality what I mean by that
every feeling every memory every color
we see every sound we hear this is
mediated by our neural hardware and
software and but it doesn't have to
match if we're talking about the sense
of sight we may see something that is
not there or we may fail to see
something that is there more generally
we may see something different from what
is there so our experience can be can be
different it's gonna depend on what the
brain is doing and if you remember the
movie the matrix there's a quote that I
like this is Morpheus talking to Neal
and he says what is real how do you
define real
if you're talking about what you can
sense and see what you can touch and
feel then really simply electrical
impulses interpreted by the brain now
this this is true I remember thinking
well they they got it right what we feel
and see and touch this is the product of
electrochemical activity in our brains
now what they were the movie the problem
of neo in the movie is that of course he
has this very dire situation because he
is being used by a battery by the
machine overlords and not all the
science in the movie made perfect sense
the battery part was was one
important point that I wasn't so
scientific however the same thing
happens to us that we know it happens to
us in our dreams
neo doesn't know he's in the matrix we
don't know that we are in our dreams
because to our brain we are experienced
in reality the reality of the dream is
real to us and what the movie doesn't
tell you is that when neo wakes up in
the matrix and when we wake up from our
dreams every thought every sensation
every feeling is still the product of
neural activity in our brains so we are
always imprisoned in this matrix that
our brains create we live in a
simulation of reality I'm going to
assume for the purpose of this
discussion that there is a real world
and this is not completely accepted but
I'm going to assume there is a real
world but you've never lived there you
haven't been there even for a visit we
live in our brains matrix and and this
matrix may or may not match reality as I
was saying we call the cases in which
the discrepancy is largest we call them
illusions but it is very rarely the case
that we have a hundred percent
correspondence and so we can say that
most of our experience perhaps all of
our experience is to a degree to a
partial degree illusory and that is both
a limitation in essence but also gives
us a tool to approach the study of
experience from neuroscience
I was asked to answer the question or to
give a short spiel on the question of
whether experience is part of the
material world and to anyone with a nose
for nonsense this question smells very
bad indeed
easier to smell a rat than to catch one
but I shall try the question I think is
at best misleading with a trivial answer
or at worst nonsense and - a question
which makes no sense there can't be an
answer in a clarification now the
beginning of wisdom in philosophy in
general is to learn not to rush into
answer questions but first to ask
questions of the questioners
[Music]
you